awesome okay hi my name is Andre
Marcello Tanner and I am from the
Philippines so hello to all my couple by
n so my talk is about accelerating the
web through am all right so quick about
me um I am from examine calm and I'm
gonna tell you a little bit a little
story take you back in the future to
2000 sorry back to pass to 2005 in 2005
we had YouTube world of warcraft hands
up beta testers and facebook who had a
facebook account in 2005 like no one
really if you had when you are awesome
see you're also you know very mature so
I didn't but in 2005 our mobile internet
looked like this we had things called
web and then everybody had to nokia
right or i guess right who owned the
nokia hold an iphone in 2005 you're an
apple developer right so in 2005 this
was the internet and in 2007 we got the
iphone which like totally changed the
internet the mobile web right before it
was all like womp in small phones and in
2005 we got I 2007 we got the iphone
we're like blown away like what is this
thing and Android was bought by google
in 2007 but they saw them they were like
we have to redo this we can't release
our keypad phone called Android so
Android reeded itself and came out a
year later in 2008 so once we're able to
view videos like this in 2007 like we
could view any kind of video right and
suddenly the web change for mobile right
and now just last year the number of
people on mobile surpass desktop it
keeps going up there are countries in
the world that are people who have never
asked access you know the internet via a
phone avaya entered by a computer laptop
or desktop are coming on
via mobile and it's not going to stop
going so we have like Africa and all of
us here in Southeast Asia right people
are coming online via their phones
smartphones it's all here people who
never use the desktop in their life are
going online via phones and so what do
we have we have websites today that load
like this right you click on the link
oops okay it's not working okay this is
a video but you click on the link and
your website loads slowly right it loads
loads it loads and loads maybe if you're
in Singapore Korea like loads instantly
unfortunately maybe you're in like the
Philippines or somewhere else in
Southeast Asia which has okay internet
it's going to load or it might fail to
load right so what is amp and if you're
from the Philippines you know you know
who this is right but if you're not from
the Philippines this is a la learn it
Dora and this is one of the most popular
thing on Twitter today and this and I'll
dub is like 27 million tweets Justin
Bieber doesn't have it say anything on
this right but everybody in the
Philippines knows about this because
they're all under mobile phones so
accelerated mobile pages was just
released last month in October it makes
superfast mobile pages it's open source
on github under the apache license and
it's basically a restricted subset of
HTML with rules it's developed within
google but it's on an open government
model so you know and this video will
not run oh it will all right we have 50
seconds and this thing will run oh you
if you how many of you have seen the amp
demo how many peeps in Google how many
people have heard of google out okay so
i can make some stuff up because very
few people know about it alright so this
is an app launch partners so we have
linked in
pinterest so if you use their app and
you click on a link that has amp HTML
it'll load that page very quickly and
they started with new site since these
are all slow sites and you know they
want people to access their content fast
but anybody can use amp nowadays so how
does it work o.o basically you take
normal HTML you remove everything
including javascript and you replace it
oops you replace it with amp special
tags and once the special tags your site
loads way faster this is the demo looks
like this you go check it out and sites
load instantly right that's not for
everybody it's not for you know all the
awesome sites we make but for content
sites yeah why not it's not you know
might not be for everybody its
production but you know thank you use it
with caution and you can get started if
you want WordPress also you can get
started right away and you can check out
these URLs to test it out on see the
difference basically okay here for
difference one point five megabytes the
app site loads in half a second when you
when you used amp compared to four
seconds loads in half a second and that
makes a difference on mobile desktop we
don't care mobile it matters bang thank
you agree